[Music]
my friends
[Music]
are you doing like that seat of your car
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're ahead of the game that's a huge
step in the right direction here you
come here you don't have to worry you
won't feed you Pig because we all need
any at all ever and every Sunday we have
this huge big
[Music]
a little bit of my
[Music]
messengerís brother home
just beat the last and final message
guess what message they came thinking of
the say no to God
surrender the Gaza ready to got now
[Music]
you know you know what we relate to this
to where people will have prostration
marks oh yeah prostrate prostrating the
god oh just like Jesus to slay all the
messengers humbly know something music
and putting it in the highest party to
the lowest punted girl I had direct my
attention to Mecca as much as poss
[Music]
mother nature did not realize okay so we
have to seek the commute or not the
creation and the creator is one alone
you will heap nothing similar for him
this is the fairest result beginning is
the last resort thing and he revealed
they understand because he loved us he
care for us you give us the direction so
we need we need understanding audience
how you can really live
you know what just let somebody what is
known as adjustability
[Music]
[Music]
all right very good experience just
actually go outside people like here
listen half an hour copy of the Koran
we'll distributed to some people you
have Russian people asking you and some
people watching you and some people you
really have to talk to them you have to
read the people face
who you got to talk to and who you are
not and all you understand that the rush
do not have time to come to so it's
experience you got to learn by stepping
outside and they try to know how you can
use it therefore lets you understand we
have to understand we do insist for our
own God friends for our own zone
it's a blessing is that world gets a
strength how you can take your belief
because if you really believe in it so
why are not telling others about also
it's the same time that you have to be
concerned for these people they don't
know they don't know and you know you
have to give the medicine you have to
give them to take the medicine to him so
I hope the ball he have to start to
develop some concern house he need to do
something for others and submission that
you give the people is an hour gives
himself the deed gives it a slam you see
cats we seen dogs we see human being
homeless poor we gives him but were not
sharing with him something which is more
important than food and air we don't
want these people to die without Islam
what noble to appeal it was anything
with him but at least something
beautiful that he need to share and they
need to be part of it Allah bless
brother 84 Putin a census life
experience today here in Chicago and
brother Matthias abbrevs us here today
who got the MJ and eight names
conference and it happens at the event
today was given hope about our so it
would have eight awesome we came here in
the corner and we started this gives the
Quran and took these people
sorry well one thing one very important
thing you understand
maybe this understand too much to give
maybe you need to flyers start to fly or
we understand something calls to attend
sent five said something understand
would be easier with the people really
country okay and this will be like Alec
step we want a stamp in the back for
more information would that be such a
such a great smell a hundred
assalamualaikum greetings of peace to
everybody how are you you come to get
some food for the so you can replete
with everything else but it's not
satisfying the soul money can't buy that
happiness it won't bring you peace not
even a six-pack of peace you can't buy
it
[Music]
[Music]